wir haben es soweit gesehen dass Ray
Kurzweil eine Techno Optimismus vertritt
und dass er virtuelle Realität ganz
stark in eine Verbindung bringt mit
technologischer Optimierung die auch
durchaus in Richtung technologischer
Ersatz geht ja vertritt die These dass
wir durch die Technologie all dasjenige
was biologisch evolutionär entstanden
ist
rekonstruieren können
aber nicht nur rekonstruieren können
oder neue realisieren können sondern
eben auch verbessern können oder
manipulieren können indem wir unsere
Natur
technologisch verfügbar machen also
duplizieren können rekonstruieren können
können wir Sie natürlich auch
manipulieren ja das
Schicksal natürlich meinte damit auch
unser Leben das Leben wird technologisch
manipuliert und
regeneriert ob das jetzt eine
Virtualisierung des Lebens ist eine
andere Frage nach unseren Begriffen
nicht es geht in die Richtung aber es
ist einfach nur eine technologische
Innovation die nicht genau dieselben
Kriterien hat obwohl sie sich auch von
der materiellen Basis löst
man muss es noch genauer diskutieren und
jetzt bringt er hier ein Beispiel des
virtuellen Körpers wie don't always need
real bodies sie sehen er bringt
Virtualität mit
Realitäten an Kontrast das sprach von
der Virtual Reality und der real reality
ist denn die Virtual Reality nicht real
er meint wohl mit reality natürliche
biologische Realitäten und mit Virtual
meinte die künstlich
every happen to be the virtual in wyoman
der Virtual body will du just fine
Virtual Reality story with the content
of computer games Hammer diskutiert
gestern der Sitzung über Ästhetik macht
oben rechts den Link dazu rein für
Youtube Party
jetzt kommt hier Simulation ins Spiel
wir müssen schauen ob Simulation
dasselbe ist wie Virtualität
intelligence to
passion
haben sie nichts anderes zu tun gehabt
als ein Computerspiel zu programmieren
das sind tätiges space surroundings für
easy to Runde justice
er spricht also von einem synthetischen
space ein künstlichen Raum als handelt
sich also um eine Simulation das ist
nach unserem Begriffen noch nicht genug
für virtuelle Realität aber es geht
weiter sagt er Computergames and
computer rise Videogames have become
morealistic over time but you kennet
completly yourself in this imagine
[Musik]
you can see the ages of the screen and
the all to real world to have never
beyond bin ich ein sehr bezeichnetes
Zitat die allzu reale Welt
die man doch trotz aller immer Version
also wird für die Realität ist wie immer
so Simulation und Imagination haben sie
alle Formen
präsentationsweisen die allzu reale Welt
haben wir nie verlassen wir sehen immer
die Kanten des Monitors und so weiter
und so fort natürlich hatte er damals
bestimmt schon
pro vorausgesehen er wollte uns nur noch
nicht sagen also seine Theorie wäre
praktisch die wir dürfen gar nicht mehr
epistemisch
bemerken dass wir uns in der wirklichen
allzu wirklichen Welt befinden das heißt
aber dann auch nur dass wir systematisch
uns
Illusionen in geben soll hochgradig
realistischen Illusionen Fiktionen und
Simulation das ist sein Begriff von
Virtualität in dieser Hinsicht ich will
going to engine
ation of virtual reality
you don't special visual takes over you
and time visual 4 Michael
Heimat reality 1993 mach auch oben
rechts in dieser Sitzung ne das ist
genau die 90er da bitte 80er Anfang 90er
da hat diese Technologie an Fahrt
aufgenommen repositions
itself the that you all look at
different Region
ziehen ist das simulated
wir haben jetzt ganz klar den Begriff
der Simulation
das sagt er hier also hier ist es
virtuelle noch mit der Simulation in
enger Verbindung
ich fasse jetzt zusammen was das
wichtige von transsumonismus ist der
Transhumanismus orientiert sich an der
biologischen Evolutionstheorie und
erweitert diese durch eine
technologische Revolutionierung in
welcher Technik und Mensch immer mehr
konvergieren
der Transhumanismus ist Techno
teleologisch teliologisch deswegen weil
er sagt es entwickelt sich auf etwas hin
nämlich auf die Singularität oder
vielleicht sogar in Richtung 6 Epoche wo
unsere Intelligenz sich von unseren
Materie ganz löst und in Energie
übergeht und sich im gesamten Universum
verbreitet der Transhumanismus versteht
Technologie als sich selbst normativ
rechtfertigend und blendet ihre ganzen
Problematiken aus er ist deswegen Techno
normativ und technokratisch damit meine
ich folgendes es sagt solange es
technischen Fortschritt gibt ist diese
technische Fortschritt durch den
Fortschritt selbst begründet also wir
haben gesagt einen Moral und die wird
dadurch begründet dass die Technik
voranschreitet das halte ich aber nicht
für hinreichend also technologische
Fortschritte
garantieren oder bringen aus sich selbst
heraus nicht die Normativität mit
technologischer Fortschritt kann sich
immer auch zum Schlechteren entwickeln
wäre es dann Fortschritt ist die Frage
zumindest kann Technologie auch wenn sie
fortgeschritten ist immer auch schlecht
eingesetzt werden Stichwort
Medienkompetenz oder noch genauer gesagt
mediale Aufklärung es kann sein dass wir
durch fortschreitende Digitalisierung
oder durch künstliche Intelligenz
irgendwann dorthin kommt dass wir alle
unsere wichtigen Angelegenheiten
telegieren das ist auch technologische
Fortschritt aber mentale Rückschritt das
heißt wir machen uns selbst unfrei wenn
die Technologie in unseren Augen besser
wird als wir dann schaffen wir sozusagen
uns ab oder
ja machen uns einer selbstverschuldeten
Unmündigkeit
entschuldigen würde kann sagen das heißt
es geht immer um den Umgang mit der
Technologie und nicht um die Technologie
selbst das ist glaube ich der Fehler den
er hier betreibt er glaubt Technologie
ist intrinsisch substanziell moralisch
essentiell
sagen so zu verstehen dass sie die
Normativität verbirgt dass sie einen
inneren Antrieb hat zum Guten hin
das ist zu bestreiten sondern
Technologie ist immer nur Technologie
durch die mensch-maschinen Interaktion
nur durch den Gebrauch und wenn man mit
dem technologischen Fortschritt nicht
auch den Fortschritt des Umgangs mit
dieser Technologie reflektiert dann
kommt meine große Probleme und diese
Perspektive blendet er vollständig aus
das heißt der Transhumanismus besitzt
spekulative und ideologische Züge der
hier in München Lehrende Philosoph Julia
niederrümelin den kennen Sie bestimmt
der hat von einer Silicon Valley
Ideologie gesprochen Silicon Valley ist
eben Kalifornien dort wo diese ganzen
Unternehmen sitzen das sei eine
Ideologie
keine Philosophie keine Theorie sondern
Ideologie das heißt wer sich nicht
diesen technologischen Imperativ fügt
was ist mit dem was ist mit diesen
Menschen die sagen ich will gar nicht
und sterblich werden ich will gar nicht
mit der Technik verschmelzen was ist mit
der er ist mit solchen Menschen nach
kurzweils technologische
normativitätstheorie müssten die sein
verpflichtet werden das zu tun weil
nämlich Technologie immer zum Guten
hinzielt wer sich dem technologischen
Fortschritt verliert der handelt
humorisch
und der Transhumanismus versteht
Personal Identität im Sinne von Software
das haben wir gesehen der mein Fall und
reduziert somit den Menschen auf bloße
Technik oder auf Informationstechnologie
das ist natürlich ein ganz klarer
Reduktionismus
ein Naturalismus ein Reduktionismus ein
technokratischer Zugang zur Technik der
sagt die Technik selbst muss bestimmen
sein und nicht unser Umgang mit dieser
Technik am Ende haben eben diejenigen
die die Technokratie inne haben die die
die den Wissensvorsprung haben die haben
die macht das ist natürlich immer auch
problematisch wie sieht es aus mit dem
öffentlichen Gebrauch der von uns dem
öffentlichen Gebrauch der Technik solche
Dinge reflektiert er nicht und das ist
ein Problem
jetzt möchte ich diesem Modell von
virtueller Anthropologie also der
technologischen Verbesserung Ersetzung
Transformation des Menschen das ist für
ihn virtuelle Anthropologie die
Anthropologie der virtuellen Realität
stark auch verbunden mit Simulationen
immersionen
eine andere Anthropologie der
Virtualisierung zum Schluss und zur
Vorlesung entgegenstellen und zwar ist
das Verhältnis von
Anthropologie und Virtualität nicht so
zu verstehen dass wir notwendige
weisenshumanismus für
wir sollten Virtualität und Mensch nicht
so verstehen dass der Mensch
virtualisiert werden muss
notwendigerweise dass der Mensch sein
Körper überschreiten muss dass er sich
in letzter Hinsicht auflöst und nur noch
reiner Geist ist das wäre die
Virtualisierung des Menschen nach weil
kurz rein
sondern wir sollten lieber die
Virtualisierung als anthropologische
Dimension verstehen Virtualisierung
verstanden als Praxis des virtualisieren
wenn wir das tun dann können wir zeigen
dass der Mensch als Mensch das jetzt
natürlich wieder ein sehr
essentialistische Aussage über den
Menschen das ist heutzutage nicht mehr
so ohne weiteres möglich solche
anthropologischen Grundaussagen macht
trotzdem um ein Gegenpol zu kurzweils
technokratischen
technokratische Anthropologie zu setzen
der Mensch hat immer schon die Tendenz
bekanntest durch Einsatz von Technologie
und Medien neu zu realisieren das nenne
ich die Alternativität und
künstlichkeiten das ist eine menschliche
grundtheit
Virtualisierung die Praxis des
neugestaltens
des durch Technik und Medien neuen
realisierens und die Eröffnung von neuen
Möglichkeiten das ist eine Praxis und
die erweist sich genau genommen als
kreative Praxis menschliche Freiheit
warum menschlicher Freiheit weil wir in
negativer Hinsicht die wir gestern schon
gesehen haben frei werden von physischen
Beschränkungen zeitlichen Beschränkung
und positiv positive Freiheit weil diese
Freiheit von uns zur Freiheit zu in die
Lage zuletzt nämlich Dinge auf neue
Weise zu realisieren wir haben das
gesehen virtuelle Realität führt dazu
dass wir nun Dinge machen können die wir
vorher nicht machen konnten die uns
vorher vielleicht noch tief erschienen
und das ist natürlich ein genuine
Fortschritt das ist aber ein Fortschritt
der nicht den Menschen transformiert
sind der eher zeigt dass der Mensch das
andere Transfer nicht der Mensch
transformiert sich sondern der Mensch
transformiert anderes und dieses
transformieren von anderen kann man eben
als Praxis des virtualisieren bezeichnen
wenn wir das so verstehen dann ist
Virtualität nichts was nur mit moderner
Technik zu tun hat sondern es ist etwas
was es immer schon gab zum Beispiel
durch Währung durch Geld aber auch wenn
es um die Bildung von Staaten geht kann
man darüber diskutieren ob das virtuelle
Gegenstände sind virtuelle Entitäten
Daten existieren ja nicht materiell hier
muss man natürlich genauer schauen was
dann starten virtualisieren deswegen bin
ich da ein bisschen zurückhaltend
Virtualisierung versteht sich dann als
eine Fusionierung also ein
Zusammenführen von Simulation und
Realität wer virtualisiert der muss
natürlich auf einer gewissen kulturellen
Stufe stehen dann muss mentale
Eigenschaften aufweisen und er muss
wissen dass sich Realität von Fiktion
und Simulation unterscheidet es ist ganz
wichtig ist eine kritische Funktion ein
kritischer Begriff virtueller Realität
der sich unterscheidet von bloßes
Simulation wir haben gesehen Kurzweil
hält dies Unterscheidung nicht überall
durch einerseits sagte es eine perfekte
immersive Simulation andererseits sagte
virtuelle Realität ist eine neue
Technologie die unsere biologische Natur
ersetzt und sogar verbessern also eher
im Sinne der
ja technologischen Verbesserungen zu
verstehen
wenn wir virtualisieren dann haben wir
ein kreativen Umgang mit der
Wirklichkeit nicht nur mit der
Wirklichkeit der physischen Wirklichkeit
sondern eben auch mit der Möglichkeit
mit der Fiktion auch der Illusion und
vor allem eben mit auch der Simulation
aber virtuelle Realität geht nicht in
der Simulation auf sondern sie endet
eben dort wo wir Neues schaffen wo wir
wieder real werden
Virtualität ist deswegen kurz gesagt
oder montiert gesagt eine Lebensform des
Menschen
also der Mensch insofern erlebt
virtualisiert immer schon ohne dass er
sein Leben virtualisiert das behauptet
Ray Kurzwahl der Mensch zu sein erlebt
muss sein Leben virtualisieren er muss
sein biologisches Leben zu einem
künstlichen Leben transformieren das ist
glaube ich zu viel verlangt da wird der
Begriff der virtuellen Realität
überstrapaziert da geht er ins fiktive
hinein sind es fiktive betrifft nicht
das was wir sagen mit der Virtualität
verbinden sondern was wir durch
virtuelle Realität verhandeln wenn wir
virtualisieren dann haben darin immer
Formen der Fiktion ihren Platz aber wir
bleiben nicht beide Fiktion sondern
versuchen eben zu realisieren nur auf
neue Weise
das ist sozusagen
mein eine anthropologische
gegenkonzeption zu ein bisschen
bodenständiger und sie ist nicht nur auf
die moderne Technologie beschränkt
sondern sie betrifft menschliche
kulturelle Praktiken generell also
virtuelle Realität ist eine Form von
menschlicher Kulturleistung die wir
immer sehen und die eben gerade heute
durch die Digitalisierung besonders
sichtbar wird weil natürlich auch
Digitalisierung und Technik im weitesten
sind eine Form von Kultur ist also
Technik ist ganz klar eine Produkt des
menschlichen Geistes aber sie lässt sich
eine Kontinuität bringen mit dem frühen
Formen von Währungen grünformen von
Virtualisierung von natürlichen Werten
und der Loslösung von materieller
Bindung das scheint mir eine menschliche
grundtenden zu sein die aber deswegen
trotz ihrer negativen Freiheit von der
materiellen Bindung nicht am Ende in
diese sechste Epoche notwendige Weise
münden muss dass losgehen sich von
unserem Körper loslösen anders gesagt
wir können nicht alles virtualisieren
das ist mein Fazit was ich hier ziehen
möchte wir dürfen die virtuelle Realität
nicht überstrapazieren alles hat seine
Grenzen wenn wir glauben wir könnten
alles virtualisieren dann begehen wir
ein Fehler weil wir am Ende
Virtualisierung mit Simulation
verwechseln wir können es sicherlich
alles simulieren oder fast alles
simulieren wenn wir es nicht simulieren
können dann können wir es immerhin
fingieren oder
illusorisch uns vergegenwärtigen
fingieren können wir so gut wie alles
wir können in der Literatur einen Roman
verfassen in welchem 1 + 1 3 gibt das
ist in der Fiktion möglich in einer
logischen Welt nach Leibnitz ist das
nicht möglich es gibt keine mögliche
Welt in der 1&1 gleich 3 sind effektiven
Welten oder fiktionalen Welten kann das
sehr gut der Fall sein wir können also
sehr wohl alles mögliche fingieren und
auch sehr viel wenn auch nicht so viel
wie das tiefe simulieren zum Beispiel
durch digitale Technik ja durch Ausgaben
können wir
gewisse Dinge
so darstellen als ob sie real sein
davon müssen wir aber eben die
Virtualisierung unterscheiden die viel
anspruchsvoller ist als bloß eine
Simulation und deswegen ist es ganz
wichtig die Grenzen der virtuellen
Realität ein sie sehen und eine
Kompetenz dafür zu erlangen wo es sich
um Fiktion wo es sich um Simulationen wo
es sich wirklich um virtuelle Realität
handelt das heißt die virtuelle
Realitäten auch die Anthropologie der
Virtualität muss immer auch
Einsicht erlangen in die eigenen Grenzen
und darf nicht zur
Selbstüberschätzung führen was lässt
sich nicht virtualisieren wir haben das
gesehen Dinge die ganz stark Körper zu
betont sind ja die können wir
zumindest nicht so leicht virtualisieren
virtualisieren lässt sich vor allem
solches was medial informationell
gebunden ist was ganz stark sozial
ontologische Dimensionen hat das lässt
sich virtualisieren hingegen das Bäume
fällen lässt sich eben nicht
virtualisieren da brauchen wir Körper
welche Kraft wir können Bäume fällen
simulieren wir können einen Computer ein
Computerspiel der Baum Simulator können
wir erschaffen wo wir eine Plastik Axt
haben und dann sagen in der simulierten
Welt ein Baum fällen dann Fällen wir ihn
aber natürlich nicht wirklich sondern
wir simulieren das Fehlen eines Baumes
wir fingieren ist wie auch immer das
heißt
physisch gebundene Praktiken die in den
physischen aufgehen die lassen sich nach
unserem Begriff der virtuellen Realität
nicht virtualisieren zu fragen ist
jedenfalls ob sich das vielleicht mal
ändern wird wenn wir künstlichen
Intelligenz einsetzen wenn wir also dann
künstlich nicht gehen zum Fällen des
Baumes einsetzen ob das dann eine Form
von Virtualisierung des baumfällens ist
als Praktik oder ob es nur im Sinne von
Ray Kurzweil eine technische Optimierung
das müssen wir uns noch mal genauer
anschauen ich möchte nur darauf
hinweisen virtuelle Realität hat ihre
Grenzen ganz klar und die zeigt sich an
körperlicher Raum zeitliche Gebundenheit
so sehr wie auch die Tendenz haben diese
Grenze zu beschreiten müssen wir
erkennen dass ich zumindest nach
jetzigen Stand und alles andere
Spekulation
nicht alles virtualisieren lässt
hingegen sehr vieles simulieren und
alles fingieren alles lässt sich von
hier meine These alles wir können alles
reagieren weil wir alles was wir
ausdrücken können eben auch fiktiven
Modus ausdrücken können alles anders
wird denken können können wir eben auch
fingieren wir können
unmögliche Dinge fingieren sie kennen
das von gewissen Erzählungen des 20
Jahrhunderts wo Fantasy und Irrealität
vermischt werden wo es ganz paradoxe
Erzählungen gibt die eigentlich logisch
widersprüchlich sind dennoch können wir
sowas regieren ob wir es denken können
ist eine andere Frage da gehen die
Geister auseinander die Meinung
auseinander kann man logisch unmögliches
eigentlich denken
wenn man denken so versteht das Ding
immer logisch widerspruchsfrei sein muss
dann nicht ja aber darüber sprechen kann
man auf jeden Fall
wenn man darüber sprechen kann kann man
es eben auch in Form der Fiktion
darstellen zumindest im Sinne der
schriftlichen Impuls sieht ja das ist
sogar mein Fazit Grenzen der virtuellen
Realität ist was sehr anspruchsvolles
wir müssen es kritisch betrachten und
ich komme jetzt auch zur Zusammenfassung
und das wollen wir uns gemeinsam jetzt
mal hier erarbeiten ich bringe jetzt
hier mal noch mal kurz alle Punkte dass
sie ein Rückblick bekommen was wir jetzt
alles getan haben und danach machen wir
noch das Quiz gemeinsam als was ich mal
zusammen und ich möchte sie auch bitten
dann noch ein bisschen zu ergänzen das
hilft auch Ihnen dann dass sie für ihr
Protokoll vielleicht noch Lücken fühlen
können erstmal ich stelle jetzt einfach
mal alles vor hier ist mal haben wir uns
mit der Begriffsgeschichte befasst
der virtuellen Realität wir haben
gesehen die ging zurück auf Thomas
implizit gehen wir schon zurück auf
Platons Höhlen gleich das ist überhaupt
immer eine sehr gute Idee Platons
höhengleichnis auf alles zu beziehen das
können Sie wunderbar auf alle möglichen
Dinge beziehen und der virtuellen
realitätsdebatte wird häufig wie Sie
wissen das virtuelle in der Höhle vor
Ort als bloßes Schattenbild das ist
natürlich dann nicht die Modalität oder
Form der Simulation sondern geht der
Illusion
und das macht auch so ein bisschen
Jürgen Mittelstraße das sagt passen wir
auf wo wir die virtuelle Realität vor
Ort streng genommen nur ein technisches
Phänomen und alles andere was mehr davon
behauptet das ist letztendlich Mode
Philosophie die Virtualität hat keine
Domäne der Wissen naja in der
Begriffsgeschichte hat sie aber eine
Domäne auf jeden Fall Thomas Philippinen
verwendet ist
Leibniz verwendet ist kann verwendet ist
und man kann zeigen dass darin wichtige
Momente auf schon
präsent sind eben der kausalen Moment
ist vor allem wichtig dann haben wir
weiter gemacht und sind zu Epistemologie
übergegangen hier stellt sich die Frage
welchen Zugang zur Welt um hierdurch
virtuelle Realität herstellen was mir
ganz wichtig ist zu Beton ist die
einschränk Einstellung die epistemische
Einschränkung Einstellung zur Welt im
Modus der Virtualisierung der virtuellen
Realität ist nicht Simulationen nicht
Illusion und mehr noch Virtualität ist
keine bloß theoretische Einstellung die
Welt wie wir sie sehen sondern es ist
eine Einstellung die praktisch ist was
machen wir mit der Welt
simulieren kann durchaus nur
theoretisches Interesse haben
fingieren vielleicht auch virtualisieren
heißt wir gehen ein praktischen Bezug
zur Welt ein nicht nur ein
erkenntnistheoretischen ganz wichtig wir
wollen etwas auf neue Weise realisieren
deswegen schreibt die App ist Theologie
über sich hinaus wenn es um die
Virtualität geht und führt auch zu
Ontologie und zu Ethik
ontologisch haben wir eine sehr
anspruchsvolle Diskussion unternommen
wir sind auf die
konstitutionstheorie von Lynn Ruther
Baker eingegangen
und haben einfach gesagt wir schauen uns
mal ein typisches Beispiel von virtuelle
Realität an was unstrittig ist und es
ist das Geld das sagen alle vieles ist
in der Philosophie strittig auch in der
Kulturphilosophie Kulturwissenschaft
aber Geld gilt gemeinhin als wie manche
sagen Paradigma oder muss der Fall von
virtueller Realität wenn sie sich das
mal anschauen ist Beispiel Geld dann
sehen sie etwas Alltägliches und es ist
etwas was nicht erst seit heute gibt
diese ganzen
touristischen Aspekte oder Konnotation
die wir mit virtuelle Realität verbinden
Scheinwelten und so weiter und so fort
künstliche Welten aber Tage die haben
hier gar nichts zu suchen wenn es um das
Geld geht das eine ganz banale Sache
keine großen Effekte und so weiter kein
Computer sie haben einfach eine
sozialontologie sehr Menschen die sich
auf was einigen und sie haben ein Medium
Stück Papier und dieses Medium kann man
jetzt weiterfahren das muss natürlich
stabil sein das Medium darf nicht in
einem Aggregatzustand sich befinden den
es unter Umständen wechseln könnte wenn
es in eine Hosentasche gelangt zum
Beispiel darf Geld nicht als materielle
Basis gefrorenes Wasser sein es sei denn
man
verwendet die Währung nur am Nord oder
Südpol und der gleichbleibenden
Temperaturen unter 0 Grad dann können
Sie Geld aus Eis gefrorenem Wasser
machen aber wenn Sie das in die
Hosentasche stecken selbst im Norden
oder Süden in einen Tierfell hinein wenn
Sie ein tierkleidung haben wird es
vielleicht schmelzen wenn sie das Geld
aufbewahren im
Iglu oder wo auch immer der werden
Temperaturen über 0°c
das heißt Sie müssen auch acht geben auf
die mediale Basis sozialontologie in der
subjektive Einigung plus Medialität oder
auch Technologie Geld hat auch immer ein
technologischen Aspekt und dann haben
wir versucht das anhand des konkreten
Beispiels ist Geld Geld ist zu
übertragen auf virtuelle Realität
schlechthin z.B eben auch anhand von
digitaler virtuelle Realität wir haben
gesehen nicht alles was digital ist ist
gleich virtuelle Realität und nicht was
was virtuelle Realität ist gleich
digital verfasst Leben das Geldscheins
gesehen hat
wir haben dann die konstitutionstheorie
von den raderbaker zugrunde gelegt die
ist ziemlich kompliziert die müssen auch
nicht in jedem Detail hier besprechen
wichtig ist nur besagte es damit etwas
ein anderes Ding konstituiert also ein
Geldschein der an sich keinen Wert hat
eine Banknote im Wert von 50 € müssen
bestimmte Bedingungen gegeben sein und
zwar Bedingung zweierlei Art es muss ein
Kontext gegeben sein der ist häufig
intersubjektiv sozial und ökologisch zu
verstehen im Falle des Geldes ist zum
Beispiel eine Institution die
Europäischen Zentralbank
plus es muss ein technologischen Aspekt
geben der betrifft das Medium oder die
Technologie das Geld der Papier schon
muss von solche Art sein dass er unter
diesen geeigneten Umständen diese diesen
Wert konstituiert ein Eiswürfel könnte
es nicht weil dessen identitätsbedingung
nicht dafür ausreichen Geldscheine
damit sie einen Wert haben müssen stabil
sein sie dürfen nicht beim nächsten
Tausch sehr flattern deswegen haben wir
zwei Bedingungen Rahmenbedingungen die
können zum Beispiel kontrakturistisch
verstanden werden dass wir uns darauf
einigen Virus sagt dass wir jetzt eine
Währung mit diesem Wert haben wollen
dass wir uns gegenseitig vertraglich zu
sichern dass wir uns dann daran halten
und wir müssen eben auch dann auf der
medialen technischen Seite sicherstellen
dass das nicht zu fälschen ist das also
der Geldschein gefeit ist vor bei
Produktion weil auch das würde dann am
Ende den Sinn der virtuellen Realität
zerstören wir hätten nicht diese
Objektivität also virtuelle Realität ist
nichts beliebiges mag es illusorisch ist
so eine knallhart-objektiv da wirken
ganz viele Faktoren mit das ist zu
dieser Objektivität des Wertes kommt
nämlich intersubjektiv
kontrakturistische Sozial- undologische
Phänomene und technologische mediane
finden
wir sagen am Geldschein der bringt schon
sehr viele
Vornamen mit Vorbedingung mit umso
komplexe wird es dann wenn es um
digitale virtuelle Realität geht denken
Sie an Bitcoin wir haben gesehen Bitcoin
virtualisiert Banknoten das heißt
virtuelle Realitäten können andere
virtuelle Realitäten virtualisieren sie
können vielleicht wahrscheinlich
physische Dinge virtualisieren wir haben
darüber diskutiert ob ein Apfel einen
physischen Wert hat ob Wert überhaupt
physisch existiert oder Wert immer schon
sozial und ökologisch ist
natürlich ist ein Wert immer ein Wert
für jemanden wenn es keine Menschen gäbe
gäbe es auch kein Wert das ist klar
dennoch können wir sagen ein Apfel hat
eine Nährwert es geht ums Überleben und
es Tauschgeschäfte haben wir auch immer
schon wieder Tauschgeschäfte natürlich
sind die sozial bedingt aber es gibt auf
naturaler Basis durchaus
Vergleichbarkeit Objektivität und es
gibt auch auf naturaler Basis Objektive
Häufigkeit und Seltenheit Diamante
Diamanten existieren einfach sehr selten
und Diamanten haben einfach Objektive
Eigenschaften die andere Dinge nicht
haben wie gewöhnliche Steine darin
könnte man aufgrund der Häufigkeit und
der physikalisch Beschaffenheit könnte
man sagen das ist so ein protrovert den
der der Diamant hat
ja dann haben wir eben geschaut wieder
durch die digitalen sowas konstruiert
wird wir haben gesehen beim Bitcoin
müssen wir
intersubjektive Dimensionen haben aber
ein sozial unter logische Dimension aber
im digitalen rückt das technologische
mediale viel Stärke in den Vordergrund
Dinge die wir früher kontrakturistisch
der Intersubjektivität an heimgegeben
haben werden nur mit einem Male durch
digitale Technik ersetzt Beispiel die
blockchain dass wir eben
Sicherheitsverfahren garantieren durch
kryptoologische
Technologien und Prozesse ersetzen
können
das natürlich wichtig für Geld gerade
für digitales Geld wenn es keine
materielle Basis hat dass wir seine
Stabilität und Objektivität garantieren
dass wir sicherstellen dass es nicht
gefälscht werden kann und das ist eben
auch nicht sein Wert verliert und
einfach verpufft ja da brauchen wir ganz
spannende und interessante Verfahren das
ist die blockchain Technologie wir haben
dann gesehen dass
wir durchaus oder vor allem vielleicht
sogar auch eine Ethik der virtuellen
Realität annehmen können wir haben uns
dieser Frage angenäht indem wir uns auf
den virtuellen Handlungsraum bezogen
haben
der virtuelle Handlungsraum was ist das
der würde
entwickelt anhand der kommunikativen
Praxis
kommunizieren Informationen austauschen
ist immer mehr als handlungssichtbar
dort wo die materielle physische
Bedeutung des Körpers immer mehr
zurückgeht wenn sie sagen sollten was
ist ein typisches Beispiel ein Handlung
dann würden sie mit Sicherheiten etwas
nennen wo ich meinen Körper bewegen muss
oder geben sie mal ein Beispiel zum
Beispiel können wir sagen Fenster öffnen
ist doch eine Handlung das muss ich dazu
machen ich muss zum Fenster gehen ich
muss greifen es ist eine komplexe
Handlung man spricht manchmal von
basishandlungen die ist bestimmt eine
einzige Aktion und die komplexen
Handlungen deren Zielerfüllung mit
mehreren Teilschritten verbunden ich
muss erst zum Fenster laufen ich muss
den Griff drehen ich muss das Fenster
ziehen sind mehrere Schritte das würden
sie wahrscheinlich als typische Handlung
angeben dazu brauche ich aber mein
Körper in der Regel ich brauche meine
Hand es braucht Zeit bis ich das mache
anders verhält es sich wenn sie im
virtuellen Raum agierende agieren sie
durch reibungslose Kommunikation da
brauchen sie ihren Körper nicht bewegen
vielleicht ein Klick mit dem Finger aber
das würden sie doch gewöhnlich nicht als
eine Handlung bezahlen schauen Sie mal
was ein Mensch im virtuellen
Handlungsraum des Internets was zum
Beispiel ein Handlungsraum ist gut rein
aus körperlicher Perspektive betrachten
sie mal seinen Energieumsatz der ist
minimal
betrachten sie mal nur von außen was da
körperlich sich vollzieht er vollzieht
sich so viel wie nichts es kann wirklich
sein sie sitzen so sie tippen ein
bisschen wegen die Finger nach oben und
unten sagen ich arbeite gerade hart ja
warum hat weil sie natürlich mental
arbeiten da oben arbeitet da unten bei
den Fingern fast nicht wenn ich ihn
gegen einen Baum fällen soll draußen der
arbeitet auch ein bisschen hier aber vor
allem hier in den Händen ja ich muss
natürlich auch schauen so nicht nichts
zu vernachlässigen ja aber es findet ein
Wechsel statt mehr zu mentalen Akten
und virtuelle Handlungsräume können das
Internet sein aber auch eben das mit
perversum also Dinge die auf dem
Internet passieren ist aber weiter
ausgestalten auch Computerspiele können
gewisse Hinsicht als virtuelle
Handlungsräume verstanden werden
Computerspiele hingegen haben aber noch
stärker simulativen Charakter und auch
effektiven Charakter
ich handle dadurch im virtuellen
Handlungsraum haben wir gesagt dass ich
Informationen austausche verbinde oder
auch Informationen einstellen sprich
dass ich am virtuellen Handlungsraum
selbst mitarbeiten der virtuelle
Handlungsraum hat die Struktur eines
Netzes es geht darum Informationen zu
vernetzen und durch diese Netzstruktur
dafür zu sorgen dass sich der virtuelle
Handlungsraum vergrößert und zu einem
Cyberspace wird Cyber habe ich schon
mehrmals gesagt Orientierung zu einem
orientierungsraum indem wir eben unser
Wissen richtig verorten und uns
informationell selbst bestimmen können
er wird schrumpfen wenn wir den Raum
nicht vergrößern wenn wir also falsch
Informationen einspeisen Fake News oder
uns in Blasen aufhalten natürlich
verstärkt durch künstliche Intelligenz
dann sind wir übergegangen zur Ästhetik
hier war ein ganz wichtiges Thema
virtuelle Kunst und künstliche
Intelligenz wir haben uns gefragt ist
künstlich Intelligenz schon eine Form
von Kunst wird natürlich viele
bestreiten aber eigentlich könnte man
auch künstliche Intelligenz als
ästhetische Reflexion auf unsere
Intelligenz sich mal genauer ansehen
würde Kunst haben wir diskutiert ein
Beispiel von
nftsible Tokens nicht austauschbare
digitale virtuelle Objekte nicht
austauschbar heißt sind Unikate und Sie
bekommen ihren einmaligen Status durch
technologische Unterstützung wie die
blockchain und durch
zertifizierte die möglichst sicher
fälschungssicher diesen Gegenstand
zugeordnet werden wir haben gesehen dass
NFC sind ein guter Kandidat für
virtuelle Kunst weil sie die
teleologische Bedeutung von physisch
gebundene Kunst bewahren
weil sie sich von materieller Bindung
lösen und weil sie zugleich neue
Möglichkeiten öffnet die vorher nicht
möglich war weil sie zum Beispiel auch
den finanziellen Aspekt ökonomischen
Aspekt von Kunst viel stärker Rechnung
tragen und unter Umständen auch den
Künstler die Künstlerin selbst im
Kunstwerk noch Präsente halten wenn es
zum Beispiel darum geht dass die eben
auch noch was dazu verdienen wenn das
Bild teurer verkauft wird oder an Wert
gewinnen sollte eine Wertsteigerung
erfahren sollte ich glaube NFC sind ein
gutes Beispiel für virtuelle Kunstwerke
wir haben gesehen dass wir künstliche
Intelligenz auch in den kunstprozessen
einbeziehen können als virtuelle Museum
das gesagt häufig wird gefragt ob
künstliche Intelligenz selbst Kunst
erstellen kann wir haben das diskutiert
anhand von zwei Beispielen einem Gemälde
das wurde gefüttert mit 15.000 Porträts
vom 15 bis 19 Jahrhundert glaube ich war
dieses Porträt von elmonte bellami und
wir haben gesehen dass diese KI aus zwei
Bestandteilen zusammengesetzt war einem
Generator und einem Diskriminator der
Generator hat auf Basis dieser
zahlreichen Daten verschiedene neue
Bilder kreiert und der Diskriminator
sollte dann schauen ob das von Menschen
gemacht wurde oder von k.i und da wo der
Diskriminator dachte es sei von Menschen
gemacht was der Generator im vorgelegt
hat da entstand dann dieses Bild man
kann das also durchaus einzelne
bezeichnet die die KI selbst mit sich
selbst macht haben sie gesagt alles eine
gute gute Beschreibung ja also die KI
verhält sich zu sich selbst die KI wird
in sich aufeinander bezogen die KI wird
reflexiv und das ist allein schon ein
spannendes ästhetisches Phänomen allein
nur der kunstprozess des Bild hingegen
war jetzt nicht so umwerfend aber ja man
kann es durchaus für menschlich halten
es fällt nicht prima Fazit auf das
könnte ein Mensch durchaus gemalt haben
so ein bisschen abstrakt ja nicht mehr
so gegenständlich 20 Jahrhundert
vielleicht das 1900 vielleicht und heute
gerade eben sind wir noch auf die
Anthropologie eingegangen wir haben den
transumanismus diskutiert der versteht
virtuelle Realität als technologische
Innovation als technologische Ersatz
oder auch als Simulation ist sich darin
nicht ganz klar und wir haben gesagt
nein nein nein wir sollten bisschen
tiefer stapeln ja nicht der Mensch muss
hier virtualisiert werden künstlich sich
von seinem Körper lösen nur noch
Software sein es sondern wir müssen
einfach erkennen dass Menschlichkeit
menschliche Praxis immer im
virtualisieren besteht ist ein
urmenschliche Eigenschaft die auch
natürlich auch viele geistige und
kulturelle Fähigkeiten schließen lässt
bekanntes
vorkommendes physisch gebotenes zu lösen
und auf neue Weise kreativ zu
realisieren und darin zeigt sich
letztendlich unsere Freiheit also mir
ist es mir ganz wichtig zu betonen
virtuelle Realität muss von dem
Freiheitsgedanken her verstanden werden
ob jetzt natürlich virtuelle Realität
und die Virtualisierung immer schon in
trinkt sich danach aufs moralisch gut
hinzielt ist eine andere Frage
man kann sicherlich auch virtualisieren
und damit unmoralisches tun das scheint
mir möglich zu sein wir haben die Frage
diskutiertes virtuellen bösen ja dennoch
und da bin ich jetzt etwas optimistisch
scheint mir in diesem Gebrauch unserer
Freiheit der sich im virtuellen zeigt
ihr das moralisch gute angelegte sein
als das moralisch schlechte weil wir
eben neue Möglichkeiten eröffnen obwohl
diese neue Möglichkeiten auch schlecht
gebraucht werden können das muss man
immer dazu sagen ja jetzt habe ich hier
ein ganz kompakten Rückblick gegeben ich
beende jetzt die Aufzeichnung und möchte
Sie bitten das gerne auch noch ein
bisschen zu vervollständigen oder
gegebenenfalls auch noch zu korrigieren